[Music]
good evening Brian you know is a artist
in so many genres I had to write him
down he's a musician he's a composer he
invented ambient music he's a producer
of all the great albums you've ever seen
he's an installation artist who's worked
all over the world he's a political
activist
and I would say not a right-winger he's
an author he's been a long now board
member from the very beginning he named
the foundation and the clock long now
ten years ago the occasion for tonight
he was the first Salt speaker he
co-designed with Danny Hillis and they
are still working on the chimes for the
10,000 year clock he came and did an
installation piece called the 77 million
paintings and he is now working on when
the salon opens for our Museum and bar
and office and everything else thrown
together at Fort Mason he will be doing
the music and visuals for that place so
in a sense you could say that one of
Brian Eno's genres is long now Danny
Hillis is an incredibly prolific
inventor yes massive parallel processing
which is the way computation happens
whenever you use your smartphone with
this gesture Danny invented that the
meta web which made Google search
intelligent as well as brilliant was
bought by Google and makes your Google
search sensible he came up with the
concept of proteomics which is a way to
basically use massive data to the body
to eventually cure cancer why not what's
interesting is that
he's prolific and he's fast he's gone
through so many inventions so never
doubt it's a tiny sample I just went
through dozens hundreds patents galore
but one invention just keeps going on 20
years ago he started inventing the
10,000 year clock of the long now and he
just keeps inventing it it was it a
difficult problem isn't an interesting
problem what is it that would make a
musician or an inventor keep bearing
down on one body of creativity tonight
we'll find out Brian Eno Danny Hillis
[Music]
good evening the piece of music you
heard was played for a reason actually
Danny and I have been on one of our road
trips for the far past few days every
year or two we we go for a drive in the
desert where he drives and I sit and
listen to him talk no it's not exactly
like that well we have long
conversations and the little box in the
front of the car keeps saying make a
legal u-turn as soon as possible because
we consistently get lost even though we
we have to GPS systems in the car we we
don't pay attention to either of them
but we during these trips we talk about
what we're thinking about and what I'm
thinking about at the moment is a new
record that I'm just finishing of which
that is the last track and as you can
hear that track is quite long and I kept
thinking as I was listening to in the
car this should be longer it already got
expanded quite a lot it started out that
end part started out as eight bars long
and it's now about a hundred and twenty
bars long and I think it needs to double
or so and I was thinking as I was doing
that why am i wanting to make it so long
why do I want it to be that long and I
guess it's because I don't want there to
be any mistake that that's what I meant
to do I don't want somebody to think
that I just accidentally made it long
[Laughter]
but I wasn't paying attention or I
forgot to do an edit or something like
that I want it to be very clear that it
is meant to be a long piece of music
that sort of stays in the same place for
a long time so I was thinking about that
and thinking about how commitment is
something that you register in in a
piece of work you register what somebody
has committed themselves to and I
remembered back to the time when I first
heard about the clock about Danny's
clock I already knew Danny then but not
very well and Stuart told me about this
idea for a clock and my first thought
was well why would you go to all the
trouble of building a thing like that
it's a very complicated problem you know
to try to imagine something that's going
to last for 10,000 years with all the
things that could happen to the world in
that time and I was thinking why would
you bother to do that though I sort of
liked the idea too but I was thinking
why don't you just sort of spread the
rumor that you have actually done it so
to save yourself a lot of trouble either
and but then over the years I started
thinking no it was actually important to
do it to actually try to realise this
thing was part of the message to try to
actually make it become real and to be
faced with all the difficulties of doing
that was part of what the thing was
about so not being virtual was part of
it
we were talking quite a lot about
virtuality and virtualization and
there's this wonderful theory by I think
it's his name is Geoffrey Miller is it
or Gregory Miller I can't remember the
man's name who theorized that the reason
we'd never heard from any other cultures
in in the universe was not because they
didn't exist but because a certain level
of development all cultures got lost in
their own ability to virtualize
experiences so basically they ended up
eating and masturbating and not
bothering to communicate with anyone
else so so virtualization is something
that we do and it's it's a sort of
internalization of experience and I
think part of this was the was the one
to externalize something sorry darling
[Laughter]
anyway so about almost 20 years ago now
the long now foundation started and of
course Danny and his clock were at the
center of that so maybe you'll start by
telling the audience a little bit about
that well it occurs to me they're
getting lost is something that we
actually do very well together yeah
we're we're very good at losing
ourselves now the reason the GPS is
always saying to turn around is because
we get into a conversation and several
times we've gone hundreds of miles out
of our way I remember particularly the
trip up from San Francisco to Monterey
where we ended up in Sacramento while we
the whole time
this GPS telling us to please make the
next legal u-turn but but that's
actually kind of a metaphor though
because there's another thing that
happens on these trips which is because
we usually don't start off these trips
with any place in particular in mind
that we're going and we just have some
time set aside and and the GPS is
actually very good for giving you
instructions to get to someplace and
that little map can kind of show you
where your next left turn is and someone
but generally we actually have no idea
where we're going yeah and and so what
usually happens is after a couple of
days of sort of frustratingly looking at
this little tiny map we finally get
discouraged and we we go over by the
side of the road and we we find somebody
who sells a big paper map and this this
sort of moment when we open up the map
of Nevada or
something and all of the sudden sort of
feels like we're in this much bigger
world that we get out of that little
world of the GPS and we're in this and
there are all these places that we will
never go and you know that really in
some sense we're not it's not that
useful to navigate by that somehow
there's this sense of relief of we're in
this bigger context and all the
possibilities of where we might go or
where we could go and in a sense I think
that's what the long now foundation is
for is it sort of that in time of all of
the normal things that we do are kind of
like the GPS we have a goal and we have
little instructions to turn left and
right and that's our normal mode of
thinking is that little view to get
someplace and every day we do that and
it's really nice to have some excuse to
kind of step back and look at a much
bigger space and kind of imagine all the
places that we might go even if we're
not going to and and so the long now
foundation I think is really an excuse
to do that and I sometimes I think we
slip in to the long now foundation I
think we slip in to coming across as if
we're trying to convince people to think
longer term but I don't think it's that
prescriptive I think it's actually much
more an excuse for us to be able to have
a conversation there's a different kind
of conversation than we normally have
and you know for for example these trips
we go on and I think many of the
activities the long now get us into
different kinds of conversations so I'm
hoping that's what will happen tonight
is we'll have one of these kind of long
now ish conversations maybe not quite
like the ones we do on the road trip
because those often have like an hour
that goes by well we think about
something the other one hours no I
actually don't agree
it's like it's like a very slow chess
game it's fun if you're doing it but
yeah I'm never mind I take that back yes
I was wrong but but this notion of a
conversation I think is is kind of I'm
starting to see it as one of the
greatest possibilities we have to
contribute to the futuristic an start a
thread of conversation yeah maybe a
different yes so so one of the things I
when when I talk about art and about the
practice of art I often use the word
conversation because I I think that you
never see a piece of art on its own you
never see it free from the rest of the
conversation that you know to date so if
you look at a painting and you've looked
at a lot of paintings as most of us have
you look at that painting in relation to
that whole conversation of paintings so
so we're constantly engaged in
conversations and what what you see when
you look at a new painting is the
similarities and differences to all the
other paintings you've seen so if some
paintings of course a completely
meaningless out of that kind of context
you know if if you think of Casimir
Malevich's white on white it's it's
hardly a picture actually if you think
about it it's a but it is an important
picture in relation to the history of
painting until that point did you know
about my white on white painting I
actually have my bones removed and
replaced with titanium and then I grind
up the to make that white and I make the
white pigment out of my own bones oh
yeah that's that's something that's very
old-fashioned Ike
I mean my my white on white painting so
really that because I am a Zen Buddhist
and they represent for me nothingness so
I think nothing is much more important
than your bones well I was I was talking
about my old words my new ones I
actually I masters at auctions a
tremendous cost and then I paint them
over with white acrylic and the art
world is completely scandalized by this
yeah yeah that's a very good idea that
I'm funny funnily enough I bought one of
yours and painted it over white but I
know I actually made a loving recreation
of that and I but I hang it upside down
but lately I mean that all this kind of
conceptual art is fun but I've gone
figurative lately and I'm now painting
snow scenes but they're accurate they're
perfectly white
I'll show you one later I've got I've
got a few examples here in fact I can
just hold one up for the audience
because mine I did the same thing much
smaller but but a big water
[Laughter]
back back to the more serious issue of
this evening however so so what
interests me is how cultural objects
like white paintings and so on help us
form our notions about things and Stuart
Stuart brand who introduced us was very
alert to that when in the late 60s I
guess it was all the early 70s he
started a campaign to release for NASA
to release the picture of the whole
earth the first picture of the Earth
taken from space and the point about an
image like that is that it changes the
way you think about things so the clock
of the long now is really supposed to be
that kind of mythic metaphorical
presence something that would make you
think differently perhaps and I had an
example of how powerful this can be
about I didn't know nearly 20 years ago
now I went to the British Museum I had a
friend working there who was the curator
of the Egyptian Department and he said
you should come sometime look downstairs
because we've got tons of stuff in the
basement that we never show and indeed
the basements of the British Museum
snake out under a large part of London
and they're filled with the antiquities
that we successfully looted from Egypt
over a period of several hundred years
and he took me around there were shelves
and shelves of dusty artifacts and on
one shelf there was a tiny little bronze
casting not more than an inch and a half
long and it was of a mother cat feeding
for kittens and this was done with
incredible precision and care and and
real love you know and it was 4,000
years old and looking at that thing I
suddenly knew more about the Egyptians
than in all the reading I'd ever done
because I suddenly realized here was a
people who 4,000 years ago
were fond of pets could have the a
loving relationship with a pet in the in
the way that we're used to doing this is
something we tend not to imagine about
people 4000 years ago so in that one
object I I think I I had more of a
feeling for Egyptian culture than all
the huge things I had seen the pyramids
and the sickness and the Vizier of
Memphis and so on and sometimes I think
an object once it's in existence can can
have that effect on you and that's what
works are active I think and so I think
the way we think about the clock now is
possibly more as a work of art than as a
functioning machine although it is a
functioning machine or will be and of
course Dan Eve I think more as a
functioning machine yeah D but I I mean
I don't know exactly I mean if the art
if by art you mean the conversation the
yeah I suppose it's a conversation piece
yeah it's a conversation piece so it's
it's sort of really meant to introduce a
conversation I think it's it's it's so
it's there and it starts you talking
about it I mean what I what I notice
when I talk to people about the clock is
they say well that that's a pretty daft
idea I mean how can you know what's
gonna happen in 3000 or 5000 years time
and of course in and then we start
talking about that and after a little
while they realize that they are
starting to do something they've never
done them before very often which is to
think about the distant future so so it
does start the conversation should we
actually try to talk a little and the
interesting thing about trying to talk
over that time frame of course is you
can't you really can't imagine it but
yeah trying to is is fun and there are a
few kind of standard I would say
standard imaginations of the future over
really long time
one of which is the kind of earth
becomes a garden and there's a poets and
artists and things who are all watched
over by machines of love and grace kind
of the robots taking care of them and
and then the other ones the road yeah
they kind of help and so that's the one
where we sort of fail to solve so
there's there's one of them one in
there's a sort of utopias where we
imagine we solve all of our problems
completely and then our biggest problem
is boredom mm-hmm
and the other end of the spectrum is
that that we imagine we don't solve our
problems and we somehow fail to and we
end up with the road or Mad Max or you
know some dystopian
of everything falling apart that's the
one that seems to be more popular in
science fiction these days yeah and
actually my guess is that the truth is
probably neither does that probably work
if you look backwards what's happened is
humanity has always had new challenges
and always kind of risen to the occasion
met those challenges and that meeting
those challenges was living and then by
the time they met those there were more
and so on so you had a series of
challenges and my assumption is actually
that that's probably what the next
10,000 years are going to be like we're
gonna have lots of challenges
they're gonna be really big problems
like global warming and we'll figure out
ways of solving those and there'll be
probably social challenges I mean I
think we've got a huge one coming off of
for instance distribution of wealth I
just I just read that the 85 richest
people in the world actually owned half
the wealth in the world Wow so you know
that's clearly something that is a I
don't think that's a stable situation
it's a good guess and but how do you
know but so you know they're there there
are challenges like that but we're gonna
have to we're gonna have to figure out
ways of setting things up ways of
relating to each other ways of you know
having our culture our economic systems
our political systems things like that
and so well a lot of what a lot of what
will happen in the future depends on
people what people expect to be about to
happen so so I think it makes a huge
difference if you think that you live in
a time where the graph is going up as we
did in the sixties or in a time where
the graph is going down as it seems my
daughter's generation do I mean
generally they don't seem to expect
things to be better they don't seem to
expect that they'll be able to just
float on a cloud and probably find a job
if they're lucky and not bother if they
don't if they're not so to me it seems
to be that at the moment there's a kind
of expectation that things are getting
slightly worse not dramatically but
slightly worse I think if people start
to think that things are going to get
much worse then a very dangerous
feedback spiral starts a kind of you
know the survivalists are the good
example of this people who think that
the future is self-defense and making a
safe corner for yourself and fighting
everybody else off that is not a
generous future so so one of one of the
reasons this is important to think about
actually is to try to see whether that's
realistic as a as a future picture
whether in fact we can come up with a
slightly more upbeat one so when when I
grew up I just this universal assumption
was everything was getting better
mm-hm and we were people I think in
retrospect were pretty naive about it
but but actually things in many ways did
get a lot better things like civil
rights and certainly economically
you know that you know I was better off
than my parents were and they were
better off than their parents were and
so on so in many ways that delivered I
mean there were unintended side effects
that people weren't paying attention to
much but you know there was definitely a
trend and then people were worried then
about sort of running out of the front
here but the assumption was that space
would be the the new friend here and I
know you and I disagree about this work
you're you're sort of giving your your
side of this but yeah my feeling is that
I can't imagine why anybody would ever
want to live on the moon or on Mars or
on any other planet I just can't imagine
it I think it's unthinkably daft idea
you know we have to be very well adapted
to this one and really badly adapted to
any of those so I think that I think the
short-term thinking in that is that you
assume that who we are sort of stays the
same yes okay so and so you know now
that we have how quickly can we evolve
well well now that we have the ability I
mean I think one of the big game
changers I mean I think there's a few
when we're alive at a very exciting time
because we have three big game changes
one of which is globalization suddenly
we're that's the the whole earth we are
one world one of which is computers
obviously but the other one is synthetic
biology we have the ability to
manipulate physically what we are to so
you know well I probably wouldn't want
to live on Venus in this body that I
could imagine adapting myself so that I
would want to live on certainly Mars and
the Mars you know I might just love
skiing on Mount Olympus and
I'm going out and having a breath of the
fresh
well argent atmosphere yes there are
there are people who have pioneer
spirits I guess a lot of them came here
of course but us who didn't come here
but don't you think over over the kind
10,000 your timeframe we're going like
that yes in in that timeframe and surely
will build starships and you know
they're probably planets out there that
are much more or flight than Mars is and
even though it takes a long time to get
there you can imagine solving the
technical problems and yeah so to me it
does seem pretty inevitable that we
probably earth is just our starting
point yes now if I if I told this story
to my daughters who are both very eco
they would say that's just an excuse for
not dealing with the problems on this
planet we're just gonna go and [ __ ] up
another one excuse me sorry
well that's what your daughters would
say I heard this very nice expression so
kids unquote it is in quotes yes
somebody said [ __ ] is the duct tape of
the English language
but if if you think about future people
and you try to think of the sort of axes
on which they'll dispose their thinking
so throughout the Cold War we
theoretically the discussion that we
were having was should it be communist
or should be capitalists so that's a
that's a discussion that Americans think
have been has been successfully and
satisfactorily resolved but not
everybody agrees but there are lots of
up there are lots of similar discussions
like that there's the optimists and
there's the pessimists well there's the
planners and the improvised planners and
the improvisers yes the the libertarians
and the status shall we say people
people who believe that as little
government as possible is the best thing
and people who believe that government
and politics is essential so there are
lots of possible long-term arguments
that will go on in the future and and of
course these things aren't exclusive
they cut across each other in funny ways
sorry
so do you imagine so actually it's kind
of an interesting question because
clearly the so when when I grew up the
we we talked about was Americans mm-hmm
and now as I got older the we I mean I
think a lot of discussion the we that we
talked about for instance that has the
global warming problem is the whole
world or at least but although you know
when we talk about we responding we it's
the West is Europe it's the yeah the
rich countries and you know there's
maybe another we in China maybe Africa
is another one you know they're there
but they've gotten to be smaller and
smaller numbers sort of bigger units
yeah and so the question is are we ever
going to get to the point where there's
a single world we that we are sort of
all feel or just this do these axes so
necessarily imply a division
yes I think that there's there's a sort
of basic engine within humans to to
create a distinction always so that as
soon as there is something that seems to
be consolidated consolidating into a
single vision there's going to be power
and distinction in making another one in
opposition to it so so I I agree with
that but I think one of the things
that's changed is it used to be that we
sort of did the we thing by connecting
it to a piece of territory and so it was
really the people that grew up around
you tended to have a similar religion as
yours they can did you eat similar foods
you know they send it they they had a
similar political framework and so when
you had these you know arguments about
say capitalism versus communism they
were associated with geographic entities
nation states
and nation states were ways of
organizing things around physical
borders and so that you did everything
in one place so in France you spoke
French and you made French food and you
you know had French culture and French
politics and so on
yeah and obviously well obviously to me
we're moving away from that it is the
only organizing principle so do you
imagine even nation-states are gonna be
around thousands of years from now well
I think that's that's a really
interesting question because they now
have a very serious competitor anyway in
the form of corporations you know we we
now have corporations that are
international and that sort of dispose
themselves at will across nation-states
of their choice and they're becoming
very powerful as as everybody everybody
knows us as sort of governmental forces
as well in that they can they can make
government's behave to a certain extent
how they want so there's a there's a
kind of natural tendency of things to
organize themselves into larger units
like for instance single-cell organisms
organizing in the cells in a multi cell
organisms or people organizing into
societies and it's kind of I think a
trend of information processing but yeah
it just does that and I used to wonder
what it would feel like to be kind of if
we were the single cells of kind of this
group mind emerging and one of the
things I realized about it is one thing
about it is it wouldn't necessarily have
exactly the same goals as you and you
would influence it but it would sort of
seem to have a life of its own and
actually I think that's sort of what
corporations feel like that really they
don't have the same goals as any of the
people in some sense they have the goals
that the employees or the goals of the
owners or the goals of the customers or
the goals you know kind of a mix of all
of those people influence what the
corporation does but in a very real
sense the corporation is a kind of a
group mine that has a will of its own
they may be different than the Wills of
any of the people yeah but don't don't
you think also that just as there's a a
tendency for things to agglomerate and
become bigger and bigger and bigger
there's also in a there still always an
advantage to the small fast unit because
the things that become bigger and bigger
and bigger
tend to become slower and slower as well
they have much more inertia they don't
they can't change quickly
so they can control a lot of things but
they don't deal with the future as well
as that's true but now we have a
different way of doing things because
now we can be parts of lots of different
things so I can be I can be part of many
I don't want to call them communities
because there's sort of one dimensional
yeah but in some sense I can I can be
part of long now and I could also have a
religion or I could also you know be a
part of a certain scientific community
yeah and and those are ways of kind of
fractionating but I'm fractionating me
as if I'm saying I'm not making the
community smaller each of those can be
very big communities they I'm not sure
we I'm not sure our brains are really
designed that way you know these are
clearly more designed for the the small
village of a few hunted the tribe yeah
yeah well and and certainly we seem to
we seem to always want to put things
together into that that small number
that we can handle and in fact if you if
you look at tribes
I think anthropologists have studied
modern tribes see that there's this
thing that happens once you get a group
that gets more than about 200 people it
does tend to split off like yes some
some division develops within the group
and it sort of splits yeah almost like
yeah well there was a very interesting
survey done by this german magazine
called dish stone about 25 years ago two
stone interviewed people in 38 countries
quite a large sample in each of those
countries in a well-chosen sample and
they asked them a couple of very simple
questions they said are you happy and do
you think your life will be fulfilled
and the two country wealth of the list
of 38 the country that came bottom was
West Germany which at that time was the
richest economic power or the most
thriving in the world actually it was
really doing very well at that point in
time the countries that came top were
Northern Ireland and South Africa
Northern Ireland was in the middle of
just about the worst IRA period and
South Africa was in the middle of the
apartheid struggles and disturbed was
having trouble trying to explain what
this result it was seemed very anomalous
but it occurred to me that perhaps what
people really value
is knowing who their friends and enemies
are there's a certain security in
knowing perfectly well that this
person's on your side and you really
need each other and those people aren't
the of course the West Germans were the
most ambiguous of all people in that
respect because they didn't dare have
any enemies they were so embarrassed by
their past that they wouldn't stand take
a stand against anybody so does the
enemy have to be another set of people
or could be an external challenge well I
think it could be an external challenge
and and I think it has been some times
in the past that people have suddenly
stood against something and it may be
again that that will happen with you
know our response to climate change that
perhaps if things get really bad will
suddenly realize that we have a real
enemy I mean state or maybe the Martians
will invade Earth yes
well States like to have enemies in it
in a certain respect because if if you
have an enemy you're allowed to have a
command economy and even democratic
states would secretly like to have a
command economy it's much easier to run
things and so so that feels to me like I
mean I think it's true of the history of
the world about that it's not true of
the future of the world so I think we're
already starting to organize things in
different ways other than by enemy well
I hope so yes yeah and I think you know
what do you think I'll lose weight well
well actually so I think that there is
there's a kind of international culture
that is a kind of global culture and
then there is fundamentalism of all
sorts is the enemy or or the people that
are organizing themselves by that being
the enemy yes
what well the switch officed s-- yeah so
these are the people who want to switch
it off so if you're a fundamentalist
Christian or Muslim and you really
believe that you've got it down the way
the world should be then in fact that
that kind of international global
culture really is a it's a real threat
to the way that you think life should be
lived yeah and it is the enemy so that
becomes an organizing principle for
those people yeah yeah so we're in a
time I think where we have the islands
of people who have and very effectively
organize themselves against the enemy of
global culture and maybe I guess global
culture hasn't so effectively organized
itself in yet it does seem to be
thriving I think well it seems to absorb
all its enemies quite easily you know it
well thrives by just being tempting the
Borg yeah it's it's it's a nice
alternative well that that's actually
another that's another possible view of
the future
aside from science fiction is that we do
somehow merge together in some world
mind that doesn't have any enemies
the Borg King and Star Trek which I
always felt with it the lore yeah the
book the Borg yes they were singer björk
[Laughter]
but you know it's a little bit I mean of
course that's meant to be a horrifying
idea but in some sense they seem sort of
happy yes villains always seem to have
quite a good time does this that's why
they say in Ireland the devil gets all
the good songs but they're not really
even villains if you sort of think that
you know they sort of like this group
mind they're more missionaries right yes
yes well of course the concept of
villainy is is also very interesting as
as we discover more and more that
people's behavior is kind of the result
of how they're built you know men with
double y chromosomes are much more
likely to be violent and in fact prison
populations have
sort of 20 times the number of double
y-chromosome people in the prisons than
outside of the prison so I kind of
wonder about that whether we find out
that more and more the things that we
have in the past criminalized are simply
the result of whatever chemicals you
happen to have running around in you no
fault of your own so what happens them
to to the idea of justice or legal
sanction of some kind do we just do we
just think well poor guy he's bound to
be violent let's build him a nice place
where he won't hurt anybody but he won't
be punished
is that a future do you think that we
that we stop thinking of good people and
bad people or good and bad things at all
and we simply think of things that we
want to avoid and things that we want to
a break embrace yeah I guess for example
one thing you know the chemicals running
around and you won't be no fault of your
own in the future you'll have you'll
have a choice yes choice of it you'll
have control of it well in in one future
in one of these yeah yeah yeah I think
but I don't know I I don't I think there
are some certainly they're sociopaths
and things like that but I guess I
believe less and less in kind of good
people and bad people in normal life I
mean Oh extremes aside you know mentally
ill people aside I think they're people
that have ideas that are in conflict
with your ideas and goals that are in
conflict with your goals and so
ultimately I think a lot of successful
society is in finding a sort of system
for dealing with those complex a
political system so I think probably a
lot of designing the future is designing
the political system of the future which
of course is not a popular pursuit in
this part of the world no I'd say it's
something people have almost given
if it's people listen the democracy is
that you know one person one vote is the
be-all end-all of political systems
that's actually I think further than
that people people in California in
particular assume that politics is no
longer really at all cooled to even
think about it is sort of it's the old
story oh yeah yeah the discussion of
politics is it comes down to sort of a
almost gossip about people its
personality the people that are doing
things but there's almost no discussion
about the actual structure of the
political system yeah
and yet it's clear that that's why it's
not working it's not you could put
really the probably the best people in
the world into the current system that
we have and they would almost certainly
act badly because they would have to to
to stay in office so somehow we've
constructed a system you know when if
you if you go back to de Tocqueville
which I know you're a fan of too or or
actually go back to the Federalist
Papers they the thing people were really
worried about in the early days of
American democracy was the tyranny of
the majority mm-hmm and the fear that 51
percent of the people would impose their
will on 49 percent but actually what's
happened partly because of corporations
and partly because of concentration so
well is the tyranny of the minority it's
people who have special interests and
have some ability to get votes either by
arousing emotions or spending money
mm-hmm that you can basically get a law
passed that is bad for almost everybody
but good for you as long as it's just a
little bit dad for everybody yeah and so
we have a political system now where
that's really the norm almost every
piece of legislation that gets passed
really is compromised
I by that effect and I don't hear much
serious discussion about you know how we
could build a different system where
that didn't happen in a world that does
have corporations and does have very
wealthy people yeah yeah well yes in a
world that doesn't assume we're gonna
just push it all away and start again
which isn't going to happen you know we
we don't have the option of starting
from scratch so we have to start from
here but I
oh he's agree with Stuart that when we
when we have about ten minutes left he's
going to cue us and I think that that
might have goodness but because we
wanted there was one thing we wanted to
be sure that we got to talk about which
was how the bells were oh yes is the
Chinese so that's our 10 10 minute
signal to talk about those but um I
better quickly song when we when I first
came to Bryan even before the foundation
started and said hey I'm building this
clock would you help me figure out what
sound it should make when it joins Bryan
discovered this remarkable you're
thinking about it and said well clearly
make a different chime every time it yes
so so we're talking about 10,000 years
and and I realized that if you had 10
bells there were about the number of
permutations of ten bells as there are
days in 10,000 years it's three million
six hundred twenty eight thousand eight
hundred permutations of ten bells so so
I thought that would be lovely if you
had ten bells and every single day in
those 10 thousand years has its unique
peal and so we worked on that on that
basis and I asked Danny if he could
think of a come up with an algorithm
that would generate those 10,000 unique
permutations at sorry three million six
hundred twenty eight thousand eight
hundred permutations so he came up with
an algorithm
which he will tell you about and and and
in fact it's it's the mechanism and the
clock and you saw pictures of this
earlier this is sorry I need to put
another like up ah I knew we shouldn't
push buttons can you see that okay well
that's that's a little counter in the
clock actually let's write a look let me
just describe the algorithm that's on
it's very high-tech stuff either we're
right at the cutting edge of okay so
imagine that tin bells are going to ring
so you sort of have ten positions which
i've illustrated by ten circles so
there's the first bell the second bell
and so on what you want is every
combination every sequence of vowels to
happen in ten thousand years so let's
say our first Bell which happens to be
the C Bell which is
that's right let's say it's in the third
position so what we want to do is we'll
lead them in the third position for say
a thousand years and then after a
thousand years we move it to the next
position and then after a thousand years
we move it to the next position and so
on so so you can see over ten thousand
years it gets to be in every position
and then what we'll do is we'll take the
next we'll take the next bell the D bell
it has eight places it has nine places
to be so we move it through each of
those nine positions during that
thousand years so about once a little
bit more than once a century it won't
move and then the e Bell has eight
positions and it will move through those
about once a decade so it will and then
so on so each each Bell moves more
rapidly and so by the time you get to
the last couple of bells the last
position is moving every day so actually
this is a nice picture this is Brian's
album cover but you can kind of see so
what the this this is the peal of bells
for the month of January 7003
so each color represents about so you
can see that these bells stay in the
same position and naturally this I think
would be the C Bell and but the higher
bells are moving around in position in
fact the two highest bells always change
position every day and so what you need
to do is basically count through so the
one Bell has to count through ten
different possible positions the next
Bell has to count through nine different
possible positions the next one counts
through eight and so on so so what these
mechanisms that you see in the clock are
this is just one of them our counters
actually maybe shows a little physical
model of the better thing so for
instance this would be the Bell that has
to count through six different positions
would have a little thing in it like
this and so every time the bell vote
counts through five positions counts
through all five it rotates around other
than
is that counter and then there'd be
another one this would be connected to
one that had seven positions and that
would be connected to one that had eight
positions and so on so that's the basic
mechanism that this there inside the
clock and it produces the sequence that
the clock actually plays and of course
the clock will only play you know one
thing in the sequence every time you
visit it at noon so if you climb up to
the mountain and go inside the mountain
through there at noon you'll you'll hear
the sequence of ten bells but we should
can we play the yes well we should tell
them actually that this isn't fictional
this this is this actually does exist
there this is being built the these
these things are about eight feet in
diameter and the real thing so not
plastic they're they're made of
stainless steel and titanium and things
like that what their last ten thousand
years they should do I mean stainless
steel is pretty durable isn't yeah it
really ought to last for ten thousand
years every part of the clock every part
of the clock that moves for example
we've tested the motion of it for ten
thousand years worth of motion so the
part that moves most often is for
instance you know the pendulum
escapement but you know bearings inside
of it things like that so we've really
tested all of those things and unless
somebody comes and deliberately destroys
it it will last 10,000 years and keep
going and still have the correct time
after 10,000 years and every day if you
actually you know go to the trouble of
going out to the desert and climbing up
the mountain and going through those
tunnels that you saw on the slides made
and climb up the spiral staircase this
cut into the shaft and go past the
machinery and climb up into the clock
chamber at noon then when the Sun goes
overhead and then the light will shine
into the clock chamber and will adjust
itself for
the chimes will come on so this just to
explain briefly before we play this this
these are not bells they're synthesized
bells and I was experimenting with the
idea of making bells with particular
properties that most bells don't really
have and in fact since since doing this
we've we have found a bell maker who's
who is making bells with very unusual
properties they can specify the set of
harmonics that they have so what you're
about to hear doesn't really sound like
any belts you've ever heard before and
it probably doesn't sound like any bells
that will ever exist it's more a sort of
proof of concept of this idea of permute
a ting ten bells so maybe you could play
that please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
having to show the cover
online forward
[Music]
that's to see that you steward you have
some questions for us
[Music]
[Music]
this all right this is for sale in the
lobby by the way and all proceeds
benefit long their foundation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so these are questions from the audience
as Phil yeah it was going through for
looking for a kind of a rowdy one
because this has been a little sacred
sounding lately yeah you're saying one
of even one of you can answer I can't
tell if it's rings it's a piece of art
there you go so actually one question we
had from Kevin Kelly you guys have been
collaborating and conversing and then
having these road trips for quite a
while now and legitimate question is
what have you learned from each other
and her since generically just Kevin s
Danny are you more artistic from
collaborating with an artist
it was make you more quote scientific
around collaborating with a science
scientist and inventor well that's a
good question I mean one of the things
that Tim Danny asked a very interesting
question a few years ago which was one
that had been bothering me as well he
was asked by John Brocklin to as were a
number other people to come up with the
question that most interested him as a
scientist he said why do people do music
and if you think about that question
that's a profoundly interesting question
why on earth would we bother to do this
or painting or any of the other things
but music is a very mysterious art in
general it's very mysterious why would
we would bother to get excited about one
color against another or one sound
against another so we've talked about
that quite a lot meanwhile when we're
driving around we play records a lot and
Danny has discovered that he can sink
which he never knew before
in fact I tried to well to some extent I
have some success in teaching him how to
sing a cappella gospel which I will not
do now don't worry but you know but
actually that I was going to not use
that example but something that fits in
with that which is I there's a there's a
kind of attitude about the world about
being in the present which I've learned
from you I've always been very much in
the future in my mind always thinking
about the next thing in it so and one of
the things that you do very often as you
will just stop will stop by the side of
the road and you'll see you know some
crumpled up piece of metal that's lying
there or something like that and you'll
just get fascinated by all the shadows
or falling on it or you know well
we'll spend 15 minutes there looking at
it from different angles and or you know
a sound that you hear you know a
transformer making or something like
that
and it made me realize that how how
little I wasn't in my own body and my
own senses I think this is partly what
an engineering training teaches you to
do is sort of abstract away from that
yeah and not actually and so I think and
as you know if I've looked even the
design of the clock I've really shifted
in thinking about where the important
things were because even though I kind
of wanted it to be about a conversation
from the beginning
mostly I thought about the kind of
mechanical things how would it work how
would the materials last for 10,000
years things like that and I think more
and more I thought about the important
part of it is what's the experience
what's the
feel of it what's the and that's kind of
a new way of thinking yeah I think this
question is one piece of in a way maybe
every 10 years long and I'll sort of
check in publicly with itself in the
world how are we doing what's going on
what's changed over this period of time
and so far it's just the same set of
people large who were around 10 or 20
years ago but we aren't the same people
anymore and a fair question to ask both
of you now 20 years older in 20 years of
actually astonishingly to easily board
people bearing down on the same set of
design questions and framings what's
changed over that period of time look
you came to us you came to this with
beginner's mind 20 years ago
well you don't have beginner's mind now
you have some other mind about this what
can you say about what what's the
differences as some Mao said when he was
asked what he thought about the French
Revolution it's a bit too soon to say
and it does seem every hundred years I
got a little bit like that now all I
know now is that I this conversation is
one that I'm having quite a lot of the
time with myself so so I the the idea of
the future is a much longer idea than it
used to be you know the future for me
used to be a decade or two decades I
might think it and now I often hear
people talking about things and I think
yeah that's true for 10 years maybe 20
years but what about a hundred what
about a thousand years so so I think I
think there has been a genuine extension
and I also is that symmetrical as the
past the deeper past
well that might was that might be
symmetrical actually because I have also
become much more interested in the deep
past as well you know I I should think
at least 50% of what I read is history
ascension here Jenny are you farther
back farther um I certainly about half
of what I read his history yeah that's
true
certainly it gives me a different
perspective when I see something I mean
mm-hmm
you know when I visited you know the
mayor is a great baguette II the you
know I saw this beautiful new building
and talked about this will make great
rubble was ordered to design that way
biofilter well-designed through the
rubble design for great rubble yes it's
a thousand you're like yeah so how are
we different than that so I think I
think again I mean maybe the one thing
I've learned about long term thinking
it's the difference between long term
planning and long-term thinking yeah say
more about that good my senses we
learned that at Yucca Mountain yeah yeah
the Yucca Mountain is a great example so
I I guess I don't really believe in
long-term planning which is trying to
take a long distance out and control the
future for a long distance so many of
our attempts to look at for instance
nuclear waste disposal are things where
you you basically try to control the
situation for 10,000 years right
and in some sense Yucca Mountain is sold
as that mm-hmm
but Yucca Mountain I actually think it's
a pretty good idea because everything is
just sitting there and they can and
within a hundred years people will go in
and get those and mine them for you it's
reversible so it's really just a
hundred-year solution but they give you
a lot of options for what to do in a
hundred years
and so I'm started realizing the right
by the way it's a lot more politically
tractable
yeah yeah to say we're just gonna Park
it here for a hundred Russian that's
right and that's indeed where we're
heading by default a less good Undergear
solution but but the idea of creating
options seems to be much more valuable
than making really long term plans yes
but but the resistance to that of course
is that people feel secure with long
term plans and people don't feel secure
with the idea that we'll always be
improvising yeah which i think is
something that we have started to come
to accept more and more I mean we hadn't
talked about okay so this the hacker
ethic was to try to make everybody into
a hacker capable of the maker movement
doing the same thing and make everybody
into a maker and in a sense you would
like to democraty with your compelled
everything else helping make lots of
people be artists you're making helping
people be invaders as more and more
people are comfortable being that kind
of creative it is this kind of
improvisational comfort come with it yes
well I would hope so I think I think it
certainly is a trend that I'm seeing I
mean actually the very interesting book
came out in England I sent you a copy
but it hasn't arrived yet it's by a
historian called David Runciman and it's
called the confidence trap and it's
about it takes picks up from de
Tocqueville and and talks about
democracy and how the sort of take home
from the book is that democracy is by
nature messy and it provides a tree and
the problems we always have with it is
is that people don't like messy and
improvised a tree so they they are very
drawn to authoritarianism time or
whatever you know and so he says the
trains are never gonna run on time just
get used to it's always gonna be a mess
at the edge of adapting at the edges of
its competence so I think one thing that
becomes clear when you look back in
history is that there kind of
three different ways that people look at
how time evolves and how now progress
happens and and they shift in importance
and dominance during different periods
so for example you know in the West
during the middle during the Dark Ages
you know that time was thought of as
very sick like that it just you didn't
expect things to be different a thousand
years from now they were pretty much the
same as they were for your parents and
your parents parents and that was the
expectation there's a wheel a regular
circle in new ism that kind of has that
idea built into it okay it's just things
go around in circles and your job in the
world like that is to kind of get with
the program and you know be part of the
cycle mm-hmm fit in mm-hmm and then
there's another kind of view of time
porches the one that I think has been
dominant during most of our lifetimes
and the arrow arrow progress that's
right we're we're doing something so if
the cycle is the kind of that picture is
and and interesting enough the music at
that time was kind of be cyclical yeah
you know and and and the music that sort
of corresponds to era of progress is
kind of the symphony yeah cuz
everything's under control and it has a
beginning and it's heading towards and
it's developing and everybody's
following the score and it's heading
someplace yes and the factory is kind of
you know you put in all kinds of random
stuff and then you get out what you want
at the end so it's all very
goal-directed and it's it's the
everything's getting better kind of you
know that we hang up that we're you know
we're gonna conquer space so we're gonna
you know just bigger and bigger
frontiers yes and so that's a that's our
kind of and then what happens with that
I that and that's the sort of illusion
of control and then you start realizing
things aren't quite so
and then there's another way of thinking
of which is more like jazz which is the
improvisation the and that basically
it's not so much that we're heading in
someplace and it's not but we're not
going around the circles either right
we're kind of going with the flow and
your job and so that so that your job in
in that kind of world is to be
responsive tune in paying attention and
okay and I think we're heading into a
time where that kind of view of where we
are is becoming more the dominant thing
we're heading out of the progress world
mindset and into the now I think that
the cycle what happens then is then not
just so chaotic that people long for the
regularity of cyclic thing and then you
know that begins to rise and question
from Tanya attention our greatest fear
is so to speak how finite our time is
how does the clock counteract that sense
of an ending and does it help relinquish
a swash or recontextualize that fear
that's a very nice question I think yeah
that would be wonderful if that's what's
happening but but I think it does in a
way I think that if you you know the the
origin of that that phrase the long now
which which was an idea that I had years
ago from when I lived in New York it was
really noticing that in New York where I
happened to live which was downtown in
edgy then edgy Soho before the bank has
moved in people lived in a very very
confined sense of both here and now so
when you when they said here they meant
these few blocks they didn't mean New
York City or America they made this
little area their sense of here was very
small and their sense of now was very
brief now for them meant from the end of
last week to the end of this week sort
of
and I was thinking how a lot of
societies have much much much more
extended sense of now you know they
think of now your actions now resonating
into the distant future and the things
you do now being the consequence of
things than the distant past
so one of the nice things about that way
of thinking which by the way isn't the
only way of thinking and it isn't
necessarily the best way it's an
alternative but one of the nice things
about it is that you diminish in
importance in to some extent your life
is not the primary event in the universe
any longer and I think that's very
consoling actually I think that death is
not such a terrifying thought if life is
not so quite so if your life is not
quite so precious and the star feature
of everything so you both diminish and
you also become much bigger because you
see yourself as kind of a thread and
something
yes larger yes so you know I I think I
do see myself much more than I ever did
is just a little thread in this story of
human existence that does go over you
know many millennia you know it's gone
over you know tinta certainly it's been
going for ten thousand years and I
believe it will go for ten thousand more
so you feel a part of something bigger
in some sense your the fact that you
know you're only a little thread of that
that comes less important yeah talking
like old men
we are yeah speaking as an even older
man I recognized the relations that
Cameron Assad es if you really explain
longing out to a child what would you
say what would you want the child to
know about the long now in a sense of
time you both have kids they've been
around while you guys have been playing
this stuff out and you've seen them be
amused or bored or whatever by it and
you've all silly you know you both
encountered public doing ages of public
dealing with this stuff what connects if
anything with the very young well of
course I never explained anything like
that to my daughters because one of the
surest ways of turning kids away from
something it's too enthusiastically
endorsed it in their presence I was
enthusiastic it was like don't explain
it for the child you [ __ ] up your kids
in my kids are just more engaged in the
fun of the activity of actually building
the clock right and to tell you the
truth I think that's mostly how I'm
engaged time right so you know these
moments to sort of step back and decide
what it all means and so on or not the
normal thing right the normal thing is
just sitting there and doing it okay
that's great basically on a 20-year
[Music]
track that got set a long time ago and
the fun is playing out and of course
we're already starting to amuse
ourselves what are you gonna do in
Nevada after the Texas clock was built
right and then and then we get in these
situations like this where you ask us
like God what why are you doing it where
you're heading and then we have to sort
of make up answers to come up with an
alibi right
question from Alex for Danny the past
you've talked about the future getting
closer with every year before the year
2000 of this when you notice that the
future shrinking that that set you in
the process of as an engineer trying to
solve the problem do you see new
horizons forming for society to imagine
the long now so was the year 2000 for a
long time what's it now if anything and
should it be anything it really was the
year 2000 right example very futurist
and you couldn't get anybody to talk
about young thousand and three just was
actually a film I don't see another
natural barrier coming up great I think
there but the global warming thing
though is everybody sort of fear of the
end in some zones and I don't think
people think past that okay so I think
and so there's a time scale that's so
set by that that's a few centuries and I
do your people now talking about that
I'm scale yeah I've done that it's the
same size problem right I don't hear
people talking much past that time scale
of like with the assumption that we get
that solved much so that maybe it's
setting the bound of the current
conversation what are you here Brian
well I hear quite a few people talking
about the singularity as though it
wasn't like that going and I'm agnostic
about it I sort of doubt that it's going
to happen because again a nice I think
will muddle along in the same mess that
we always have done them if it does
happen we won't notice it really isn't
just happened it will carry on you know
maybe it has happened actually and then
I think what to shared maybe is passing
in the night it has happened in it it
did not know the sauce that's right in
there with the torch nations there are
aliens and they're already here they're
just very small
in fact that's what the singularity went
is into these little creatures Julie
Hammond s henwood sorry-ass could you
share about a challenge or a problem
you've had in your life that presented
an urgent the an urgent problem yet you
approached it over a lengthy period of
time with a long time frame about it I
am so sorry I do you think you've got
any personal problems a personal problem
or a problem that you took personally
you don't have to go completely soap
opera here but something I mean of
course every day I do it in designing
the clock I mean I have right right so
you know I ran into the Y 10k bug in
Microsoft Excel the other day explain
that
there will be Microsoft stories for the
next 10,000 years
no it just doesn't handle five-digit
your numbers it's are exactly how did
this Express I was building a
spreadsheet calculating the position
various years would be in in different
times and flesh yeah it did it wrong so
I think in the design the clock
certainly every day I run into specific
things I mean for example but global
warming mmm-hmm which is kind of this
abstract discussion if you're designing
the synchronization system for the clock
where the Sun shines down the whole
world lights up mm-hmm you actually have
to be able to calculate the altitude of
the Sun which means knowing what day
what day it is a certain amount of time
from now which means knowing how fast
the earth is spinning and if your earth
warms and the polar ice caps melt it
actually makes a significant difference
in how fast the earth is spinning yeah
and so you have to build actually a
correction system into the clock because
of global warming that actually takes
into account the possibility of maybe
the ice caps will melt and maybe they
won't
so the question been Mauro how I know
what climate change will the clock
withstand and so so the answer is it
will withstand melting the polar ice
caps it's very high it's in six thousand
feet up yep it in it will on in Texas is
six thousand feet yeah great okay
and it's designed that for example
handled big changing weather patterns it
doesn't need a sunny day except once
every ten years or so so I it is
designed with the assumption that there
will be things like volcanic eruptions
that's you know you don't get a clear
sky for ten years it is designed to
assume that you know the average
temperature may get hotter or colder in
the area that it is rain
you know we're designing it in a desert
but it you know it may get a lot more
rainfall so we're taking that into
account so this is pretty pedagogic it's
rather wonderful in a way there's the
clock by dealing with these problems
then invites the people who think about
the clock now or visit the clock and
awhile to engage basically the design
process then you had to go through of
thinking what kind of stuff happens over
the long term and then how do you invent
literally right now of talking to the
climatology community asking for weather
predictions under climate change
scenarios for the the spot where we're
building the clock what are you getting
we're getting people who have
speculations you know you know things
that could happen nobody's willing to
say this will happen but we're trying to
get the range of things that people are
saying could happen okay mystery you
know is the zen buddhist how do you
reconcile the aims of the ten thousand
year clock project with the buddhists a
notion of impermanence asked eric
schneider
I'm actually not a Zen Buddhist but well
I'm so much for that
not embarrassed to be described as one
but what are you absolutely you have any
belief structure whatever that sounds
like an accusation no I don't think I do
actually I feel I think I'm a you're a
somebody who believes in in the muddled
the model I'm a medallist I'm not I more
and more think that things just muddle
along only everything just over rituals
that muddlers muddled marvelous muddled
is like me surrender to the muddle and
love the process of surrendering to the
muddle see more about surrender Brian
Eno well surrender yes that's a subject
that I'm very keen on shall I talk about
that or Zen Buddhism surrender which
you're not totally unrelated to go ahead
no I'm a dancer I'm sure I can find a
way to tie these my answer to this
question
it's an old interview his trick so I
suppose I started making the kind of art
that you saw before we came in of these
big light installations and the kind of
music I've been making for a long time
sort of suggests to people that they
should just let it happen to them that
they should surrender to it and indeed
the kind of behavior I see in my shows
my visual shows is of people slumped in
chairs in the semi-comatose State
and that's actually the state I like to
be in as well I'm very happy in that
state and I thought about this and I
thought why do we like doing this
because clearly a lot of people do like
doing it they come not only to my shows
but they do lots of other things that
involve surrender like they go to
churches or they go to parks or they sit
by rivers where nothing much is
happening or they have sex with each
other and surrender to that experience
or they take drugs and that's a kind of
surrender as well you know so I started
thinking there's this kind of umbrella
which I call surrender and underneath it
under the umbrella are sex drugs art and
religion at least and a few other things
as well those are all activities in
which you deliberately lose yourself you
stop being you and you let yourself
become part of something else
you let part you surrender control of
some things and of course this is a big
theme in sane Buddhism as you know but
is actually
the the the idea being that you know
we've had about 5000 years of increasing
technical control and we we pride
ourselves quite naturally and quite
reasonably on the fact that we are very
good at control and of course we we all
enjoy the consequences of it you know
the results of it on the other hand we
had about two or four million years of
mostly having to surrender mostly having
to go with the flow of things and mostly
having to learn to deal with whatever
was thrown up by nature and the
surroundings and I think surrendering is
a great gift that human beings have and
I think that one of the experiences of
art is is relearning or rehearsing or
continually trying again to be able to
surrender properly to be able to let
things be out of our control and to live
with them and I suppose that the one of
the things about the the idea of
thinking in terms of in a very long
period of time is what I was saying
earlier of losing that sense of yourself
as the single focus of the universe's
existence and seeing yourself as
surrendering to the idea of being one
small dot on this long line reaching out
to the edges of time in each direction
so anything about its aim for this I
think that didn't have any is there any
other elements of a surrender you're
trying to build in for the experiencer
of the clock in the mountain well I
guess I've come to increasingly
appreciate that maybe that's what I was
saying of what I've learned from Brian
because I think when I was trying to say
if so that the the be in the moment
except the I mean being an engineer I'm
normally in the mode of not surrendering
and fighting it and 22 wrestle it into
the thing
you want it to be and so for me being
able to get out of that mode which is I
do think the mode that you're in when
you're looking at the crumpled up piece
of metal down on the road yeah
it's you're not trying to get it to be
anything that's right they're just
trying to take it for what it is and
yeah and that's um so you're using this
consciousness to design a place which
will be dark and out of time and scary
well so exactly so there are some
specific things to try to get you to do
that kind of surrender mm-hmm so for
instance one other thing it does is that
it first of all it forces you to get
away from your environment for a long
time
mm-hmm by being far away you have to
spend a couple of days just getting
there mm-hmm and then it forces you by
where it is on the mountain to wake up
really early so you're sleep-deprived
and you're waking up before dawn to get
up to the mountain before noon and then
you go through this physical exertion
climbing up that mountain is not easy
and also it deliberately gets you into
kind of a state of confusion a little
bit of fear oh really maybe thinking
you're in the wrong place maybe all
that's really to get you to leave behind
all that idea of you know your plan your
control all your you know it's meant in
some sense get you to surrender I mean
I've never really thought of it that way
before but Jacy get you to give up on
the idea that you're in control of the
situation and then that all sets you up
for at the moment when you get to the
clock and there's more scary things that
happen long away as I recall this or
overhearing some of the design
conversations like that this is this
300-foot spiral staircase that's cut in
living rock is I recall us you go up the
stairs get narrower and narrower like
what's that about well that's again
putting some sense that okay so for
example one of the things that does is
you go up this here
case and so when you're at the top
looking up there you think you know
where you're going because there's some
lighting literally a light at the end of
the tunnel which you're heading up
toward right but as you get up there the
stairs get smaller and smaller in fact
eventually they taper off to so small
you couldn't possibly walk on them and
so you sort of see that coming up and
you realize how my my plan isn't going
to work
and so that's an example and then you
know at some point you know you go off
in a different direction of course there
are ways forward but they're there
different ways that maybe you thought
you were expecting and so you end up
coming to turn away from get away from
that idea of progress and heading toward
the light and pick a side track and so
those are deliberately designed in to
kind of get you out of maybe kind of
fool you into thinking for a minute you
you have a plan and then I think you
realize you don't you're not you're not
in control of the situation
that's life we're gonna wrap for the
evening thank you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you